Speaker 1: I want to start today with some rare
good news when it comes to just the process of
voting in the United States. You know, we're
we're waiting to see whether Democrats will be
able to push forward the voting rights bill
that Joe Biden has been talking about now
intensely for the last week or so. But
absent that, there are so many different ways
in which Republicans are not even fighting the
so-called battle of ideas which they claim to
prioritize, and instead fighting to win elections
by subterfuge and deception and systems control,
rather than winning people's hearts and
minds. So gerrymandering is one of these ways
that Republicans have sought to and have
benefited from manipulating the system,
reducing ballot boxes in minority neighborhoods,
limiting voting hours, trying to stop mail in
ballots, mandating specific IDs, including IDs
that require that while themselves may be free
required documents which, if you don't have
them, are not free to obtain putting in place
Partizan actors to oversee the count or
whatever the case may be, it's relentless.
It's exhausting. And the first element of that
that I mentioned is gerrymandering. And we have,
you know, you've got to look at this big battle or
this big war and the different battles within it.
Within the battle around gerrymandering.
We have a little bit of good news in one of
those sub battles, and that news is that the Ohio
Supreme Court has decided to throw into the trash
the Republican gerrymandered maps and has given
10 days, 10 days to fix it. The AP reporting the
Ohio Supreme Court declared Republican drawn
legislative maps invalid Wednesday yesterday,
agreeing with voting rights advocates that the
lines were unconstitutionally gerrymandered
in a four two three ruling. The court sent the
maps back to the Ohio Redistricting Commission
to take another crack at complying with provisions
of a 2015 state constitutional amendment,
which requires there be an attempt at
avoiding Partizan favoritism. These
maps in Ohio are so gerrymandered that there isn't
even evidence that they tried to avoid Partizan
favoritism. Justices gave the panel 10 days and
retained jurisdiction to review the handiwork.
The dispute comes amid the process of
redrawing legislative and congressional
district maps that states must undertake once a
decade to reflect changes from the U.S. Census.
There's a bunch of interesting elements here,
one of which is Republican Gov. Mike DeWine,
a member of the commission and whose son
was among Wednesday's dissenting justices,
pledged in a statement to work with my fellow
redistricting commission members on revised maps.
Think about that. Republican Mike DeWine is a
member of the redistricting commission and his son
is one of the justices of the Supreme Court who
said the maps are fine that my dad was involved in
in in drawing and writing. I mean, it's it's, you
know, there are so many ways in which this is just
absolutely insane and you've got to fight these
battles one by one. And this is the difficulty
when they have so many ways, you know, they
talk about winning the battle of ideas.
And the problem is they've lost the battle of
ideas. When you look at the country and you say,
do most people believe that the government
has a basic duty to provide some health care
to everybody, regardless of ability to pay?
Very popular statement not reflected in our
elected officials, not reflected in the actions
of our elected officials. When you say, well,
what's the position on abortion nationally?
Well, legal in most cases is the opinion of
more people than ever before in the United States.
Is that reflected in our elected officials? No.
They're not winning people over in
terms of hearts and minds in policy.
They're winning with gerrymandering, making voting
difficult for the people that they think would be
to their advantage to make voting difficult for
all of the other things that I mentioned. And
then when you even take the war and then you look
at one battle gerrymandering and you look at that
battle in one state, Ohio, you find, oh, one of
the guys who was involved in drawing these lines,
which are crazy Partizan was Mike DeWine. And
one of the justices on the Ohio Supreme Court
deciding as to whether those lines are OK or
not is the son of Mike DeWine. It's just it's
truly stunning that this is what's going on
in this country, but it is. And so we've got
to fight these battles one by one, the battle.
It's not even that it's been won yet. In Ohio,
there's the opportunity to win it by getting more
fair maps drawn. They have 10 days to do it now,
nine since the decision was yesterday. We'll
follow it and we'll let you know what happens.